Welcome students
to the Pharmacology
of the Cancer Drugs.
This is part one.
We'll talk about the
conventional ones
that have been around
for years, decades.
They are non-selective
cytotoxic chemotherapy.
Please don't be alarmed
at the number of slides.
I will actually only be talking
about fewer than half of them.
The rest of them
are introduction
slides, title slides,
pictures, questions.
I will take time
on the questions.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
Please contact me if
you'd like some help.
You may be asking
yourselves, why do I need to
know this if I'm not
planning to be an oncologist?
Because the primary care
physicians and all healthcare
professionals are members
of the Cancer Survivors
Healthcare Team. You will
be seeing patients who
are on cancer drugs, who
have been on cancer drugs.
The learning
objectives are typical
mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms,
pharmacokinetics.
And I'll just go right
through all of these.
I put the drugs into
this table to help you
see exactly what it is
that you need to know.
The drugs are on the left
-hand side, the drug classes,
I should say, and the
mechanisms are on the right.
Of course, that's not all
you need to know. You need
to know mechanisms of
resistance, mechanisms of
anything related to the drugs,
mechanisms of toxicities.
The next lecture will
talk about the biologic
and small molecule agents
that I've listed here.
The hormonal anti
-cancer therapeutics
are not covered in
this lecture. They
will be covered
next year for you.
Let's take a look at
some general concepts.
The goals. Well,
to rid the body
of malignant cells, certainly.
If cure is not possible,
then the goal is to
shrink the tumors and
relieve the symptoms.
Drugs are not the
only method for
removing cancer. in a patient.
Also surgery, radiation,
and anti-cancer
drugs frequently
used all together.
We need to always remember
what are the patient's goals.
This is just normal DNA
structure and replication.
I'll let you have a
look at this to get you
into the context of
what we're talking about
with the damage to the
DNA that the drugs cause.
The cell cycle.
These are the phases
for proliferation.
G1.
That's when the cell
is accumulating all
of the products
that it needs, the
proteins it needs to
move towards mitosis.
This point is a
checkpoint. It's called the
G1 checkpoint, obviously,
because it's in G1.
DNA synthesis phase
here in the S phase.
The cell is accumulating
all it needs for mitosis,
duplicating the DNA,
getting ready to move into
mitosis, And we have another
checkpoint to make sure
that the DNA is going
through intact and normal.
And then the mitosis phase.
And the cycle starts again
in proliferating cells.
Here we have white blood
cell in apoptosis. please
notice it's more or less
falling apart and it's got
it's coated all these little
particles are coated in
membrane so that it's not
damaging any tissues around
it we're going to be talking
about alkylation anti
-metabolites for DNA synthesis
and cell division and
then part two was going to
be the targeted therapy.
All of this requires
apoptosis, I
should say, requires
intact proteins that
will trigger the
apoptotic pathway.
The theme of the apoptotic
pathway, you certainly don't
need to memorize it, it's
just to give you an idea.
We have chemotherapeutic
targets intracellularly
because we are damaging
DNA from the inside.
We have targeted
therapeutics that act
externally and also act
internally on particular
metabolic pathways
of the cancer
cell and that can
trigger apoptosis.
And mechanisms of
resistance. Many of
these will seem
familiar after learning
about them and for
antimicrobial therapy.
With the cancer drugs,
if the tumor is able
to repair the DNA,
it will go on to proliferate.
If the systems that are
involved in repair are not
functional, believe it or
not, the tumor cell will go
on to proliferate. The
reason this is important is
because these pathways increase
cell damage as they ligate
and, I'm sorry, as they
snip and re-ligate in their
repair. If the repair systems
are not working, we're
not getting that function.
And if we're not getting
that function, we're not
going to trigger apoptosis.
or apoptotic pathways
are impaired. The
tumor cell will go
on to proliferate.
Decreased accumulation,
we see this
with the antibiotic resistance.
Increased expression of
drug detoxification, so
glutathione conjugation,
anything that neutralizes free
radicals. Target alterations
or the ability to bypass
a target and tumor cell
continues to proliferate.
Evasion of the immune attack.
This is the most recent
strategy is to prevent
evasion of the immune attack.
and I put it in this
little chart to try and
help you visualize it
chemotherapy treatment
strategies slow-growing
cancers we just have to put
in something that gets
into the DNA and wrecks
it basically so that the
apoptotic pathway gets
triggered rapidly
proliferating cells DNA
asynthesis and mitosis
interrupt those processes.
Endocrine therapy, I'm not
going to go into that one.
Multi-drug combinations
because it maximizes
the effect and
hopefully minimizes the
development of resistance
to the cancer drugs.
Maximum individual
doses are administered
as frequently as
possible. Don't
forget, chemotherapeutics
are toxic.
And the conventional
chemotherapeutics really
are poisons. They
poison the tumor and
they poison proliferating
non-cancer cells.
So maximal doses
depend on the time that
the body needs to recover
from side effects.
Neutropenia is the big
one, so the decrease
in the white blood cell
count, the type and
the stage of the cancer,
the treatment goals.
Are we attempting
to cure the patient?
Is it merely palliative?
ideally we would like to
avoid major toxicities
bone marrow suppression
peripheral neuropathy etc
nephrotoxicity hepatotoxicity
but it's not always
possible and then the common
toxicities we have the
ability to at least reduce
the severity of them we
have antiemetics we have
some very good ones now,
painkillers, and then
non-medical strategies.
Toxicities.
Chemotherapies disrupt DNA
function in proliferating
normal cells along
with the tumor cells.
Pharmacokinetics and
toxicities of cancer
drugs vary among the
individual patients.
therefore it is
absolutely essential
to recognize the
toxicities early
monitor for them alter
the doses if that's
appropriate for relieving
the symptoms and reducing
the risk and vigorous
supportive care dose
limiting toxicities i'll
be talking about with these
conventional agents.
These are specific adverse
effects of a drug
severe enough to prevent
an increase in the dose.
That's the definition.
And the dose-limiting
toxicities are critical
for determining the
maximum tolerated
dose, which is done in
the clinical trials.
So these are averages. we
still have our individual
patient. I put the adverse
effects, the toxicities
here in this chart on
the right-hand side. You
see, you may notice that
they're all related to
rapidly proliferating normal
cells, except this one.
metabolic complications
of tumor of
chemotherapy are this
thing are this syndrome
called tumor lysis
syndrome and blood
cancers normally also
called liquid cancers
the chemotherapy is initiated
and massive destruction
of the tumor cells in the
blood occurs and these
tumor cells just dump their
contacts, contents into the
blood, leading to this
tumor lysis syndrome related
to increased uric acid,
increased phosphate, decreased
calcium and hyperkalemia.
So you can just imagine.
Drug-specific toxicities,
many of them will
cause hepatic, renal, and
neurotoxicity. Many cause
pulmonary, and some
cause cardiac toxicity.
And then secondary
malignancies.
Leukemia is one that
is common to most
of these conventional
chemotherapies.
Teratogenicity,
fetotoxicity. And then the
targeted drugs have
their own set of
toxicities, which we'll
talk about in part two.
Alkylating agents
is the first group
that we're going to talk about.
These are cell cycle
nonspecific. They
interfere with the
integrity of the DNA.
These are often used
for the slow growing.
Cancers,
which many of them
are responsive because
something called a neutrophilic
the attack which I'll
get into and the next
few slides okay this is a
typical structure of a drug
this is the first one that
was used met clorethamine
it converts to this this
nucleophilic molecule and it
will hook up to the reactive
molecule the reactive
atoms on the purines and
pyrimidines. We see here this
is the alkylated N7 guanine,
which is a typically reactive
site for these drugs.
And when there are two sides
bifunctional, like this
one, it's going to hook up
to another N7 guanine, an
alkylated. And this action can
cause inter and intrastrand
cross-linking which leads
to the DNA just breaks.
Importantly, in order
for cell deaths to occur,
the apoptosis must be
triggered and responsive.
So essential
mechanisms. First it's
got to recognize that
there's a lesion.
Then the checkpoints
proteins have to be activated
then the mismatch repair and
DNA damage repair systems
need to be intact so they
come in and they induce more
strand breaks in order to
repair the enzymes they do
a snip and then they do
a ligate so when there is
massive DNA damage and there
are numerous sites in which
the repair systems need to
be responding in terms of
single strand and double
strand lesions then there can
be massive damage and the
apoptotic pathway will be
triggered and for the result
to happen apoptosis there
must be functional p53 and
other proteins that trigger
apoptosis and mutations
in p53 and these other DNA
damage repair proteins can
cause the tumor cell cycle
to just move forward and
the cell will proliferate.
Now these drugs are not
used alone we don't use any
drugs alone for unless it's
palliative then we might
because of the we want
to reduce the risk of
resistance developing and
we want to increase the
efficacy I put this same
chart here of toxicity so you
can And if you learn it
once, you don't have to
keep learning it for
each individual drug. I
included here the alkylating
agents also can cause
amenorrhea and azospermia.
It's usually reversible.
Okay, cyclophosphamide
is not the first one
that was developed, but
it is so widely used.
I am going to just
be talking about
cyclophosphamide. the
only alkylating agent that
I'm going to mention,
and there are many.
You may be tested on
the boards with many of
these alkylating agents,
but if you get the
idea of this one, when
you're studying for the
boards, you'll be able
to understand the rest.
So here we have pharmacokinetics,
really important
with cyclophosphamide.
and also I-phosphamide.
Here we have cyclophosphamide
and hepatic metabolism
using CYPs to
this form, this 4
-hydroxycyclophosphamide,
which then can be inactivated.
This is the pathway we
want to look at here.
4-hydroxycyclophosphamide
gets converted to aldo.
Phosphamide, which
is then converted to
the phosphoramide
mustard and acrylene.
It is the phosphorified
mustard. If you see
mustard, you know it's
an alkylating agent.
That is the anti
-cancer molecule.
So aldophosphamide via aldehyde
dehydrogenase is inactivated.
All right, let's talk about
acrolein for a moment.
Acrolein has nothing to
do with cancer. It does
not have any anti-cancer
activity, but what it
is is an irritant. When
it accumulates in the
urinary bladder, it can
cause hemorrhagic cystitis.
So hemorrhagic cystitis
is an important
adverse effect of
cyclophosphamide.
To review, cyclophosphamide
is a pro-drug.
It's converted
through these various
pathways to the
phosphoramide mustard.
aldophosphamide is also
converted to acrolein
aldophosphamide is inactivated
by aldehyde dehydrogenase
cytotoxicity well
alkylation it's just exactly
what i described before
with the inter and
interstrand cross-linking
it also causes abnormal base
pairing miscoating strand
breakage, of course,
depurination by removal
of guanine residues.
So just as non
-selective, it gets into
the DNA and it
virtually splits it up.
Resistance? Well, increased
expression of aldehyde
dehydrogenase. I'm
sure you remember that
aldophosphamide is
inactivated by aldehyde
dehydrogenase. So if there
is a higher number of these
enzymes available,
a greater amount of
aldophosphamide will be
inactivated and therefore will
not be converted to the
phosphoramide mustard.
Also glutathione
transferase for
detoxification of
the intermediates.
pretty straightforward
all right what
do we use it for
this is the takeaway
cyclophosphamide is widely used
in the treatment
of solid tumors
hematologic cancers
and it is a potent
immunosuppressant for
autoimmune disorders
that's it that's all i want you
to take away from this slide
sorry i keep pushing
the wrong button
toxicities now let's
talk about acrolein and
hemorrhagic cystitis
well we've got something
to help first of all
there has to be vigorous
hydration so we saline
solution at high rate in
order to go through the
kidney and dilute the
acrolein, but we also have
something called mesna, and
this is the chemical
structure here, very simple.
Here's acrolein, and it
just hooks up with it.
That's it, and carries it
away, so that reduces the
potential for acrolein
producing this direct toxicity
to the bladder, And then we
have, in addition to that,
bone marrow suppression. We see
that with the
alkylating agents.
Congestive heart failure.
This is important
toxicity because
cyclophosphamide is
used with other
agents that also cause
cardiotoxicity.
I'm circling it. I want you to
remember the congestive
heart failure.
And arrhythmias,
cardiotoxicity.
So,
acrolein with mesna
reversal or antidote,
bone marrow suppression,
and cardiotoxicity.
What class of drugs induces
cell death by nucleophilic
attack on DNA bases,
especially the N7 guanine,
leading to interstrand and
interstrand cross-linking,
abnormal base pairing,
miscoding, a strand breakage?
the alkylating agents.
The DNA damage activates
the DNA repair systems
that create DNA strand
breaks by repair enzymes,
which activates the apoptotic
pathway. The answers,
of course, are all at the
end of the presentation.
I hope that you'll
try and answer
these without looking first.
What cellular mechanisms are
essential for cell death?
recognition of the addict,
intact MMR and DNA
damage repair systems to
induce DNA strand breaks
by the repair enzymes,
normal p53 gene, activation
of checkpoint proteins,
and resistance develops
rapidly when a drug is
used as a single agent,
which doesn't answer the
question, but it's an
important concept to recall.
And active metabolite,
phosphoramide mustard.
So cyclophosphamide itself
is a prodrug converted
through this pathway
I have here to the
phosphoramide mustard, which
is the alkylating agent.
What is the name of the
urotoxic metabolite,
and how can the
toxicity be mitigated?
Acrolein, mesna.
What is a mechanism of tumor
resistance? I should say,
what are mechanisms?
Increased expression of
aldehyde dehydrogenase
increases the rate of
metabolism. Increased expression
of glutathione transferase
detoxifies alkylating
intermediates. And what is
cyclophosphamide used for?
Numerous solid and
hematologic tumors and
immunosuppression and
autoimmune disease. And what
are some common toxicities
of cyclophosphamide?
Bone marrow suppression,
liver toxicity,
cardiotoxicity. I didn't
have these on the previous
slide. Lung toxicity,
malignancies. These are
class effects. Got to
remember the class effects.
Now moving to the
platinum drugs.
Platinum coordination
complexes, platinum
analogs. I have a
few different names.
I have stars on cisplatin,
carboplatin, oxaloplatin
because they're all really
important for you to
recognize. They could all be
on the boards and you will
likely have patients who
are on these drugs if
you see patients with cancer
or who have had cancer.
All right.
It's platinum. It's a metal.
So it gets inside cells
through the copper
transporter and it degrades
the copper transporter on
the way. And there can be
some passive diffusion too.
you'll read about that.
Then it undergoes
a process called
aquation. This is just water.
Water replaces
the chloride ions.
So we have water on
both of those sites
and that is highly
reactive, that molecule.
Therefore, this highly
reacted molecule
gets into the DNA,
very similarly to
what we saw with the
alkylating agents.
We see that kind of indicated
here in this picture
with the intra- and inter
-strand breaks, and that
will cause an induction of
the DNA repair pathways,
the MMR, and if
apoptosis pathways are
functional, then
apoptosis is triggered.
So it's nonspecific, just
gets in and messes up the DNA.
resistance decreased
uptake so how how was the
uptake decreased well if
the copper transporter
is down regulated or
if there's decreased
expression of it so the
drugs do not move in
that's as you can see is
the predominant mechanism
these two molecules the
i should say transporters
are efflux transporters
and they're copper effluxed
transporters. They're in
our cells naturally in
order to regulate the levels
of copper within cells.
So platinum, the
platinum compounds,
can be effluxed via
these transporters.
Drugs can be
inactivated. This is
actually the reactive products,
glutathione, metallothionine,
metallo so that tells
you platinum and some
others or repair the tumor
is capable of repairing
the damage and that's I'm
sure you can see it's
intuitive all of these
mechanisms and this is a
figure that demonstrates what
I was just talking about.
The copper transporter.
We see our glutathione
and metallothionine
and our copper
transporter efflux pumps.
And this is another
efflux pump called MRP2.
And this is just
a picture of the
actual mechanisms
that we talked about.
common features.
So I'm talking
about all three now.
All are IV. All don't
really get into the CNS.
All are cleared renally.
Dosage adjustment and renal
impairment. Whenever you
see this, think this.
Synergy with radiation therapy.
So I mentioned before,
surgery radiation
and chemotherapy
are commonly used
together this drug
drug interaction I
won't be talking too much
about drug drug interactions
other than drugs that
have the same toxicities
but this is an important
one T before P T is the
taxane which I'll talk
about in a little bit and P
is platinum so taxane has
to go before the platinum
in a sequential infusion.
So taxane patients goes
in, receives the infusion
of taxane, and when that's
completed, receives the
infusion of the platinum
compound. And this mechanism
isn't really clear.
This was discovered in
clinical trials that the
taxane really needed to go
before the platinum because
if it's the other way
around, then there's a
greater risk of the taxane
bone marrow suppression.
So if we give the taxane
first, we have limited bone
marrow suppression caused
by the taxane and increased
efficacy because the taxane
levels are not decreased.
All right, cisplatin,
covalent binding to
plasma proteins, non
-enzymatic inactivation,
vigorous saline solution,
which I'll get to
when we get to that
dose-limiting effect,
vigorous saline solution,
and a long half-life.
Major anti-tumor activity
in a broad range of solid
tumors. I'm not going to
list them here. Just remember
it's effective against lots
and lots of solid tumors.
Carboplatin. The takeaway
message with carboplatin
is it's less reactive
than the other two.
There's less renal and GI
toxicity. We still need
some hydration, but it
doesn't need to be that
same vigorous hydration
because it doesn't cause
that nephrotoxicity that
we see with cisplatin.
Also a broad range,
broad spectrum drug.
Oxaloplatin, again,
it's highly reactive.
Now the cytotoxicity on
this drug does not depend
on that activity of the
mismatch repair system.
It's probably related
to its structure. What's
it used for? It's not
used for as many things.
I put here the colorectal
and gastric cancer.
I've included here
FOLFOX. This is how the
cancer regimens are
talked about in letters.
I'll go into this more
as we get to more drugs,
but this stands for
folinic acid, this stands
for 5-FU, and this part
stands for oxaloplatin.
oxaloplatin is a component
of the first-line care
chemotherapy for advanced
****** and colorectal cancer
which is very difficult
to treat cancer all right
dose-limiting toxicities
nephrotoxicity with cisplatin
we need that vigorous
chloride diuresis with normal
saline Plus, usually, a
diuretic to reduce toxicity.
Different experts have
different opinions about that.
Highly emetogenic.
About 100% of patients
will experience the
vomiting from cisplatin,
and it's persistent.
It happens early on, and
it can happen days later.
And, of course,
there's not just one
toxicity. We have
toxicity to the nerves,
toxicity to the
ears, ototoxicity.
Think about other
drugs that cause
ototoxicity, like furosemide,
which is a diuretic.
Bone marrow suppression.
Whenever we have
proliferating cells, think
bone marrow. Whenever
we have damage to
proliferating cells,
think bone marrow.
And, of course, nerve toxicity.
carboplatin as I
said before it's less
reactive so it's more
tolerable to patients
bone marrow suppression
being the major dose
limiting toxicity and
oxaloplatin is peripheral
neuropathy and this
is something that it
has its own kind of
idiosyncrasy which is And
the acute toxicity is
exacerbated by cold.
So patients are often advised
to protect their hands
when they're reaching into
the freezer or have someone
else take out the frozen
food, wear gloves when it's
cold out, that sort of
thing. And then there's a
delayed progressive
neuropathy. that and neuropathy
peripheral neuropathy is that
feeling of pins and needles
in the hands and feet fingers
and toes and hands and
feet and up part way up
the arms and legs and it's
painful and it really impacts
the patient and then all
of them can cause leukemia
pulmonary fibrosis months
to years later. These are
really delayed toxicities.
How does the mechanism
on the platinum analog
compare with the mechanism
of the alkylating agents?
The alkylating agents
have a nucleophilic attack
on DNA causing all that
cross-linking and activate
the repair mechanisms
that triggers apoptosis.
The platinum analogs
diffuse through the copper
transporter. They are then
acquitted to positively
charged molecules, and
those molecules produce
a nucleophilic attack on
the DNA. Cross-linking,
activation of DNA repair
mechanisms, apoptosis.
And platinum
analogs bind also to
nuclear and
cytoplasmic proteins.
Of course, as always,
for apoptosis to occur,
the apoptotic systems
need to be intact.
And what are the
main mechanisms
of resistance to
platinum analogs?
E-flux, inactivation,
loss of DNA, mismatch repair,
and I forgot to
mention reduced influx.
What is the definition of
dose-limiting toxicities?
Specific adverse effects
of a drug that is
severe enough to prevent
an increase in the
dose. In other words,
increasing the dose, the
patient just will not
be able to tolerate it.
And specific, these
dose-limiting toxicities
are critical in
determining the maximum
tolerated dose during
clinical trials,
especially in oncology.
So that's where the dosing
recommendations come
from, the clinical trials.
What are the dose-limiting
toxicities of the
platinum drugs?
Cisplatin, nephrotoxicity,
carboplatin, bone
marrow suppression,
oxaloplatin, peripheral
neuropathy, acute and delayed.
And sequential
administration of a platinum
analog with paclitaxel
or docetaxel.
Why is the taxane
administered first?
To limit the myelosuppression
or bone marrow
suppression of the taxane
and increase the efficacy
of the combination, the
taxane in particular.
Pharmaco, and this is the
reason. I put it down here.
You can read it at the end
when you see the answers.
Antimetabolites now.
We're moving away from
the alkylating agents,
from the platinum
agents, and we'll be
talking about drugs that
act in the S phase of
the cell cycle, the
phase in which the DNA
is being synthesized.
Definition. An
antimetabolite is a substance
that is similar in
structure to a metabolite
or enzymatic substrate,
and it interferes with
the normal division
and function of cells.
Antimetabolites are
analogs and competitive
antagonists of
natural substances.
The natural
substances are folic
acid, pyrimidines, and purines.
Antimetabolites inhibit
nucleotide synthesis,
which depletes the
pool of nucleotides
necessary to synthesize
DNA and also RNA.
Antimetabolites induce
cell death in rapidly
dividing cells by interfering
with DNA synthesis.
Those are the principles of
mechanisms of antimetabolites.
The toxicity is pretty
much what we saw with
the alkylating agents.
There's nothing different
here. So I'm not going
to read you this slide.
Let's talk about
methotrexate. It is a folate
antagonist. antagonist. I've
indicated here why it matters
and what folic acid's
function is in the body.
Looking at the structures,
they look nearly
identical, don't they? And
I've put arrows showing
the differences with the
methotrexate structure.
pharmacokinetics matters
with methotrexate for
cancer it's administered
in these high doses that
we talked about IV for
prevention of cancer in the
CNS for acute lymphoblastic
leukemia It's given
intrathecally right into
the cerebrospinal fluid.
For immunosuppressant
indications, we see oral,
IM, sub-Q. It's given in
low doses once weekly.
Now, methotrexate, remember,
looks like folic acid.
However, it's taken up
by the reduced folate
transporter. Folic
acid is converted by a
dihydrofolate reductase
to active folate. It's
called the F4, the
tetrahydrofolate version.
it's bound to plasma proteins
and if it's displaced
because it is so toxic at
these cancer doses increase
displacing them from plasma
proteins can increase
the risk of toxicity even
if it's only transient
the toxicity can be
substantial just because that's
what methotrexate does.
Narrow therapeutic window.
Poor CNS ***********.
You could have
figured that out when
you saw intracecal.
However, very very high doses
can ********* into the CNS.
The kidney and liver
can accumulate the drug.
Nephrotoxicity and
hepatotoxicity.
Methotrexate is a
substrate of several
efflux pumps, and
this is a regular
uptake transporter
for the liver.
Now, once it gets inside,
methotrexate, like
folic acid, gets some
glutamates put on
it, polyglutamation.
And this is active.
It's active for folic acid.
It's active for methotrexate.
The original tetrahydrofolate
is active. The
original methotrexate is active.
So all of that is active.
But once the glutamates are
on it, it becomes charged
and it will not go back
out of the cell. It remains
inside the cell where it
will do its toxic action.
And therefore, it has a
long biologic half-life.
That's what I'm
talking about here.
Whatever is not
inside the cell goes
out through the
kidneys, unchanged.
the doses of course is going
to depend on the patient
for the half-lives so the
half-lives are measured in
the patients who have are
receiving them for cancer
treatment children and adults
you don't have to memorize
that just get the concept
okay here's the mechanism
that's been recognized for
the treatment of cancer.
Methotrexate and
the polyglutamate
block dihydrofolate reductase.
It's right here on the chart.
And that will
decrease the active
tetrahydrofolate
synthesis naturally.
And decreased tetrahydrofolate
is going to reduce
the synthesis of
thymidylate and also purine
nucleotides necessary for
RNA and DNA synthesis.
Additionally,
because this is blocked,
mesotrexate and the
polyglutamates are going to
increase in concentration
behind that blocked
dihydrofolate reductase.
And that accumulation has
been found to cause direct
inhibition of thymitylate
synthase, which is
needed for DNA synthesis,
and these other factors, which
are needed for
purine synthesis.
In any case,
cell cycle arrest,
activation of P53, apoptosis,
and cell death in the S phase.
Dihydrofolate
reductase, thymethylate
synthase, and these other guys.
Methotrexate resistance
impaired transport,
so it doesn't get in.
The reduced folate
transporters are reduced
in number, for example.
Increased expression of the
drug efflux transporters.
This is multidrug
resistance protein.
production of
dihydrofolate reductase
that doesn't bind
to the mesotrexate,
increased concentration
of dihydrofolate reductase
so that folic acid is
able to be synthesized, is
able to be used to
synthesize tetrahydrofolate,
and reduced ability to
produce these polyglutamates.
It's mainly this
accumulation of polyglutamate
that is responsible for
mesotrexate function.
Broad spectrum,
mesotrexate is just like
the platinum drugs,
like cyclophosphamide.
It's just used in so
many combinations.
Solid tumors, hematologic
tumors, childhood acute
lymphoblastic leukemia.
It can produce cures.
for ALL.
Autoimmune disease.
We saw that with the
disease-modifying
anti-rheumatic drugs.
Abortifacient. Well, it
is fetotoxic, and this
abortifacient effect, this
fetotoxic effect, puts methotrexate
as a treatment for
tubular ectopic pregnancy.
Bone marrow suppression,
mucositis, stomatitis,
nausea, vomiting, diarrhea,
hepatotoxicity, pneumonitis,
that can occur at any time.
Neurotoxicity,
so it's the same list that
we saw with everything else.
Fetal loss.
Reproductive toxicity,
the impaired fertility.
And Leucovorin rescue.
The other name for
leucovorin is folinic acid,
but I'm going to refer
to it as leucovorin.
But you can see folinic
acid looks like folic
acid. It is actually an
active form of folate.
It is converted to this, active
methylene tetrahydrofolate.
And it's used as a
rescue to rescue the host
cells from the toxicity
of the methotrexate.
It is given after the
infusion of the methotrexate,
after 24 hours after
usually or thereabouts.
It is given in one or two
or three doses, depending
on the dose of methotrexate
that was given.
It will rescue the patient's
bone marrow from the
toxicity, liver, and GI
toxicity. That said, it's
not going to reverse
neurotoxicity or pulmonary
toxicity, but at least
it will help salvage the
host cells from the toxicity
of the methotrexate.
Polinic acid,
leucovorin rescue.
Looking now at 5
-fluorouracil, I put a star on
capocytamine only because
it is a pro-drug of 5
-FU. And if you know 5-FU,
you know capocytamine.
This one's injectable.
This one's oral.
Here's uracil,
fluoropyrimidine, fluorouracil,
and here's fluorouracil.
Structural analog of uracil.
5FU is converted to, with
phosphorylation,
to these forms.
And I put a hyphen in there so
you can tell the difference.
Distributed throughout,
gets into the
brain, gets into
the CSF. I keep
pushing the wrong
button, I am sorry.
Metabolism, here's the enzyme,
dihydropyrimidine,
okay, pyrimidine,
that's uracil, dehydrogenase.
And this is in the liver,
other tissues as well,
and that will convert 5
-FU to a non-toxic form.
Now, 5-FU is also
partially metabolized to
carbon dioxide, excreted
by the lungs, obviously.
So not much goes
through the urine.
Half-life, plasma half
-life, not very long,
but it is taken up
into the cells, and
therefore the biologic
half-life is prolonged.
Kappa-citabine I mentioned
is just the pro-drug.
now pharmacogenomics the enzyme
pharmacogenomics must be coming
patients with deficient
dehydropyridine dehydrogenase
are at risk for a severe
excessive toxicity because
the 5-FU is not being
detoxified so for a given
dose there is a much
greater concentration of
active drug. This is an
autosomal recessive trait.
Fortunately, we see
deficiency in DPD only rarely.
Okay, action.
I hate buzzwords, but this is
a buzzword. I mean less death.
So let's take a look.
Number one,
the 5-FU is converted
eventually to
the deoxy form.
Then there's this
5-FU, so 5-fluorine
deoxyuridine monophosphate,
hooks up with
folate, which hooks
up with thimitolate
synthase, so we get
this three-way complex.
And that complex, therefore,
inhibits the activity
of thymidylate synthase.
And thymidylate,
which is thymidine
monophosphate, is not formed.
Thymine less death.
No thymine, then DNA
can't be synthesized.
Now, that's not the
only thing that happens.
The drug can be triphosphorylated,
incorporated into
DNA, and that's going to
cause DNA strand breaks.
And also by similar
pathway, the RNA pathway,
it can be taken up into RNA
and that will inhibit
the synthesis of RNA.
Pretty straightforward.
We have the analog.
It's an antimetabolite.
It does what the
metabolite would do, only
it blocks everything up.
Resistance.
well if it doesn't get
converted it's not going
to work if there's another
substrate that it doesn't
bind to it won't work
what do we use it for
lots of things but i'm
bringing back this full fox
folinic acid leucovorin
which is full
of folinic acid
5fu and oxaloplan
and another one
we're going to talk
about arenotecan
it's the same concept
topical it is used topically
for certain skin cancers
class toxicities bone
marrow suppressions gicns
neurotoxicity something called
hand foot syndrome as seen with
5fu it can be seen with
other toxic drugs as well.
But 5-FU is known for it,
and especially capocitabine.
Capocitabine in
particular, because
capocitabine is a pill,
and it's taken daily.
5-FU is usually given by
an infusion over several
days. So I have a picture
of that hand-foot syndrome.
And then we can see some
cardiovascular issues here.
They don't happen very
often but we still need to
be looking for them okay
this is the hand foot
syndrome see all of this
erythema here and eat the skin
can actually peel off so
that's disclamation here
we see some stomatitis
the redness around here
They're in the red tongue
because they're inflamed.
Prelimiting analogs. Now
we're looking at cytidine.
Sorry, cytarabine.
It's also called erycea
because this is a
ribose and this is
an arabinose. That's
why it's called era.
Arabinose. I spelled it wrong.
Gemcitabine is a
commonly used drug. I'm
still not gonna
talk about it though
because Cytarabine
will give you the idea.
Pharmacokinetics, of
course, it's injected,
distributes to the CNS.
It is degraded by cytidine
deaminase. If you see
deaminase, you know that's
an inactivation enzyme.
in the liver.
It's high in many
normal tissues, and
that's the whole
concept with citerabine.
Cells that have high levels
of cytidine deaminase
are less likely to develop
the toxicities that
we see with the cancer
cells that the citerabine
treats. Well, citerabine
doesn't treat that
much, but cytidine deaminase
is lower in cells of
acute myelogenous
leukemia and that's what
cytidine is that's what
cyterabine is used to treat
and of course it's
taken up into the
cells and we'll
see how that works
so cyterabine now we have of
kinase deoxycytidine kinase
recognizes the
structure of cytarabine
and therefore it gets
triphosphorylated.
All right,
triphosphorylated. So what
are we thinking
about? Well, it will
block the effects of
the DNA polymerase.
Competitive inhibition
of DNA polymerase.
The alpha will block the
DNA synthesis and the beta
will prevent repair. so
alpha the first step beta the
second step and it's
incorporated into the DNA so
that'll block chain elongation
that'll activate the
checkpoint proteins and apoptosis
mechanisms of resistance
well it doesn't get
converted to the active form.
There's decreased transport,
so it doesn't get in,
and increase in the
deactivation. So that's it.
Drug of choice for acute
myelogenous leukemia
is given with this
Rubicin or this Rubicin.
There's nothing else
really to remember about
cytarabine. I've got the
toxicities down here.
See, it's everything
that you've seen already.
And the CNS toxicities.
So the purine analogs,
I'll talk about 6
-mercaptopurine. That's
the only one I'll mention.
This is the pathway,
6-MP. It's a pro-drug.
It gets converted to sioenosine
monophosphate by this enzyme,
hypoxanthine guanine,
phosphoribosyltransferase.
I've got the definitions
down here for you and that
gets converted to these
toxic nucleotides that's
the main mechanism there's
also a side mechanism
over here where it inhibits
de novo purine synthesis
now it's inactivated by this
pathway siopurine methyl
transferase and this
pathway, xanthine oxidase.
Here are some pharmacogenomics
we need to be thinking about.
Slow metabolizers, because
of reduced activity of
thiopurine methyltransferase,
are going to have a
reduction in this inactivating
product, which is just
going to shunt the 6-MP over
to these other pathways.
Now, a drug interaction, so
allopurinol and other drugs
that block xanthine oxidase,
we're not going to get
this pathway, so it shunts
it to these other pathways.
In any case, if this
is blocked, or if this
is blocked, and
certainly if both are
blocked, we're going to
get an increased risk
of the toxicity caused
by mercaptopurine.
And therapeutic uses,
acute lymphoblastic leukemia,
some various regiments, and it
is a potent immunosuppressant.
It is actually used
in Crohn's disease.
Toxicities, just
what you expect.
And here's our drug interaction
that I just mentioned.
Just back up a minute.
So why do we care about
xanthine oxidase? Well,
this drug treats ALL,
which is a hematologic
cancer. So when the drug
is first initiated, you
get this massive killing
of the leukemia cells,
and what comes out?
Uric acid, among
other products.
What do we use to treat
uric acid increases?
Xanthine oxidase.
That's why it matters.
How do we manage it?
The recommendation
is to decrease
the dose of the
6-mercaptopurine.
What structural and
mechanistic features
are common to the anti
-metabolites class?
Analogs of natural substrates
interfere with DNA
and RNA synthesis.
Inhibit nucleotide synthesis.
deplete the pool of
nucleotides necessary for
RNA and DNA synthesis,
cell cycle arrest in
the S phase, cell death.
And how does inhibition
of D-dihydrofolate
reductase lead to
cell cycle arrest?
And here we go. So,
polymethotrexate, glutamates,
dihydrofolate reductase,
decreased tetrahydrofolate, and
pairs RNA and DNA synthesis.
Plus, we get this other
action due to accumulation
behind the block dihydrofolate
reductase in which
thymethylate synthase and
other enzymes are inhibited.
How does leucovorin
reduce bone marrow,
liver, and GI toxicity
of methotrexate
therapy? Because it
replaces active folate.
What is the mechanism of
action of fluorouracil?
Well, it gets converted
to 5-F5-fluorodeoxyuridine
monophosphate, which
complexes with folate and
thymetylate synthase and
blocks thymetylate synthase
and therefore blocks
DNA synthesis.
Also it will get
incorporated into RNA
and DNA and prevent
their synthesis.
What is the function
of Leucovorin in
the Folfox regimen
which I actually
didn't mention to you but
it's very very important.
we talked about lucovorin
being a rescue agent with
methotrexate that's not it's
purpose here I said that
5F the fluorinated
deoxyuridine monophosphate
complexes with folate which is
uridine monophosphate
just does that
so by using this
leucovorin it's going to
stabilize that bond with
thimitolate synthase and
that will increase the
inhibition of the enzyme
and efficacy of the
full fox treatment also
full ferry which is
arenotecan which i'll talk
about when i get there
so please know this part
Leucovorin is given
just prior to the 5
-FU. With methotrexate,
leucovorin is given
about 24 hours after
the methotrexate.
What drug is a cytidine
analog activated to the
triphosphate deoxyform, which
inhibits blah, blah, blah,
citerabine?
It inhibits DNA
polymerase alpha
and beta and also
is incorporated.
And poor metabolizers
are at increased risk of
mercaptopurine, and that's
thiopurine methyl transferase.
This is just a summary
of the anti-metabolites.
I know it's probably got
confusing along the way.
Which takes us
to our anti-tumor
antibiotics. Why are
they called antibiotics?
Because the original ones
were derived from the
streptomyces microbe, which
is a gram-positive bacterium.
and the others were semi
or semi-synthetic so
doxorubicin is the only
one i'm going to talk
about donorubicin was
the first one i mentioned
before that it's
donorubicin is given with
citerabine for treatment
of aml but that's just
about its only use
doxorubicin is super important
IV,
let's see, what do I want
to, we'll talk about that
it's protein, sorry, p
-glycoprotein substrate does not
cross into the CNS. We see
our CYPs are involved here,
so we have to be thinking
about drug interactions.
It goes out through the
feces, not the urine, and
the half-life is multi
-phasic you don't have to
memorize that anthracyclines
are red they just are
that's a natural color
so you can think rubicin
think ruby think red
and they can turn urine
red and that can be
concerning to the patient
but it's just the drug
coming out that way
plex mechanism of action
topoisomerase 2 inhibition
i'll talk more about that
when i get to that enzyme.
In any case, we get
our doxorubicin or our
rubicin, topo-2, DNA
complex, so they're all stuck
together, and that causes
irreparable DNA breaks
and apoptosis. Then
it can get into it,
intercalated, so it inserts
between the base pairs
that causes the uncoiling,
blocks the synthesis
and repair and that causes
the strand to break.
And free radical formation
is semiquinone oxygen
and oxygen free radicals.
They cause damage
to all types of products
within the cell proteins
and DNA and that causes
the strand to break,
and also membrane
damage. Forgot to mention
that. Causes damage to
the membrane function.
Okay,
multi-drug resistance
is common, and what
we're seeing here is
efflux, mainly efflux, but
also inactivation
of these semiquinone
radicals, oxidative
radicals, decrease their
mutations in the topo-2
increased repair break.
Cardiotoxicity. This is a big
thing with the anthracyclines.
Cardiotoxicity.
Cumulative dose
-related, so over time.
Irreversible progression
to cardiomyopathy
and acute left
ventricular failure.
So this is a delayed reaction.
It's very difficult to treat.
Patients who do
experience this might
actually need a
heart transplant.
A more acute kind is this
pericarditis or
myocarditis syndrome.
Now, bone marrow suppression.
Neurotoxicity.
CNS toxicity.
And then these are quite
irritating. So we can
get the extravasation
and necrosis of tissues.
Radiation recall,
I have a picture of
that. And of course,
secondary cancers.
So this is a picture
of radiation recall.
This is just sun. The patient
was irradiated, but then
much later went out in the
sun and the sun this is
damaged from the just from
the toxicity the radiation
recall basically and you
see it's blistering it's
terrible here we have necrosis
caused by extravasation
doxorubicin and trastuzumab
we'll be talking
about trastuzumab they
both cause cardiac
toxicity. And when you
add cyclophosphamide
to the group, we get
more cardiotoxicity.
Paclitaxel plus
the anthracycline,
we talked about T before P.
And the anthracycline
should be administered
before the taxane
here, A before T.
and then we have regular
metabolic and transport
related things okay natural
products they're the
vinca alkaloids and the
topoisomerase inhibitors
oh I'm sorry the mitotic
inhibitors that's these
two and the topoisomerase
two let's start with the
vinca's these are called
natural products because
they come from plants.
Vincristine is the only
one that I have a star
on. All of these tend to
have different properties,
but I'm just going to
talk about vincristine.
IV, p-glycoprotein
substrate, doesn't get much
into the CNS. We have
our CYP3A4 again. Now,
this is a never forget.
Intrathecal administration
is contraindicated.
It can cause
terrible CNS damage.
Some patients might have
such terrible damage,
they even lose their legs,
and it can be deadly.
Mechanism of action,
it inhibits microtubule
polymerization. And I'll talk
about that on the next slide.
Multidrug resistance
is common. I talked
about that with
the anthocyclines.
So we get cross-resistance.
These are a number
of the efflux pumps.
Multidrug resistance.
Multidrug-associated
resistance protein.
Breast cancer
P-glycoprotein.
protein or mutations
in the site of action.
Vincristine,
pediatric and adult
leukemias, lymphomas,
and solid tumors.
Vincristine is the
treatment of choice to
induce remission in
children with leukemia.
Neurotoxicity is the main
dose limiting toxicity. I
have a slide to demonstrate
this in a few slides now
constipation this is
peculiar we don't usually see
this we usually see diarrhea
then christine constipation
**** severe abdominal
pain and obstruction and
again extravasation it causes
blisters at the injection
site and then we have
our CYP, P-glycoprotein.
Here's the activity.
Bank of alkaloids bind to
beta tubulin and block the
polymerization of that beta
tubulin so microtubules
are not formed. And in
that way, It blocks mitosis
in the metaphase, and that
will lead to apoptosis.
Now,
the taxanes.
This is the natural product,
and it comes from the yew tree.
Cell division, again, it
prevents the cell division.
Paclitaxel and docetaxel are
both very, very
important drugs.
So I've underlined some
important pharmacokinetic
properties here.
Paclitaxel, docetaxel, both
P-glycoprotein substrates,
CYP3A4 metabolism,
***** excretion of metabolites.
paclitaxel has non-linear
clearance non-linear and
this is probably not hasn't
been definitely shown but
probably related to the fact
that it does not dissolve
in the iv fluid and the
diluent so it has to be
mixed together with this
castor oil product and that
could be the reason why it
has non-linear clearance.
NAB paclitaxel
is a nanoparticle
albumin-bound paclitaxel.
It is soluble in
aqueous solution.
And cabazitaxel is a leader
addition to the group
and it might be more
useful in certain
cancers where the MDR
proteins are expressed.
High potential for CYP
-mediated drug interactions.
Now,
taxanes bind to the beta
-tubulin and stabilize the
microtubules so that the
polymer does not disassemble.
this causes defects in the
mitotic symbol a spindle
assembly chromosome segregation
cell division and the
microtubules accumulate cell
cycle arrest and apoptosis
broad spectrum these
drugs are broad spent
cabazitaxel not but
the others are broad
spectrum of solid tumors
that's a takeaway with
the therapeutic use
resistance we see is MDR
genes again and mutations
in beta tubulin.
Toxicities,
these are the dose limiting
effects, the ones on the top.
Peripheral neuropathy is
known as glove and stocking.
I'll show you the picture
on the next slide.
Radiation recall again, fluid
retention,
extravasation, and AB4T.
So you can see the
similarities from
one group to the
next to the next.
Now I put this peripheral
neuropathy slide here
because the vinca alkaloids
and the taxanes are so
well noted for it, but
notice how many other drugs
can cause peripheral
neuropathy. But I'll just
put vincas and taxanes,
and here's our platinums.
Vincas and taxane, taxane,
oxaloplatin, vincas and taxane.
So at all of these
various locations,
we get damage to the
peripheral nerve.
Glove and stocking.
Gloves, stockings.
Now, camptocesans
comes from this tree,
camptoceca acuminata,
from the bark.
Just arenotecan is the only
one I'm asking you to remember.
And these are some structural
important features
of the structure.
Requirements is the C20 here,
chiral center, and the
C10 hydroxyl group.
Renotecan is a pro-drug, and
it's converted to this SN38.
So SN38 is the active form.
Topotecan is not a pro-drug.
It can be closed or open
ring, and it's the closed
ring form that's active
of SN38 for Renotecan.
the the rings are closed
and open are in dynamic
equilibrium and i circled
some important features
of arenotecan ugt1a1 is
required for inactivation
of sn38 if ugt1a1 you
that's udp glucuronol
transferase, 1A1, is in
low levels, low activity,
then there will be greater
concentrations of the
SN38, increasing potentially
the adverse effects.
Diarrhea is an important
toxicity of arenotecan.
It can be severe. It can
cause hospitalization.
Mechanism of action.
Camptothesis is
topoisomerase one inhibition.
Drug binds of the
topoisomerase and the NIC DNA
complex. The DNA strand
resealing is prevented. The
single strand break in the
DNA accumulate and eventually
the replication fork
collides with the complex
and that will cause
irreversible double strand
DNA break and that will
lead to cell death.
And the mechanisms of
resistance, probably
pretty much the same
as the other ones.
Arenotecan, numerous
solid tumors. And here we
have the full theory for
colorectal cancer, metastatic
colorectal cancer. It's
the same combination
we saw, only it's
arenotecan instead. It seems
to be equally effective
to the full FOX regimen.
bone marrow suppression
both of them
diarrhea dose limiting
for arenotecan
please remember the diary it's
really terrible
it's really terrible
antipipidophilotoxins this
is a topo 2 you can remember
it by looking at the
double l here in the name.
Myelosuppression, bone
marrow suppression,
is the dose-limiting toxicity.
Numerous cancers.
Okay, it's the same
idea. It's the formation,
however, of the drug
with the DNA in the Topo2
complex. We saw that with
doxorubicin, and that
prevents the resealing of
the double-stranded DNA.
Oops, hit the
wrong button again.
The enzyme remains bound
to the free end of the
broken DNA strand, and
what happens is these DNA
breaks accumulate, and
therefore we get apoptosis,
cell cycle arrest in
late S and the G2 phase,
and the usual mechanisms
of resistance.
A broad-spectrum
chemotherapy therapy causes
irreversible cardiotoxicity
that can lead to left
ventricular dysfunction,
cardiomyopathy, and
heart failure, apparently
resulting from the
generation of free radicals
and lipid peroxidation.
What is the mechanism of
action of this drug? So
now I'm asking for the
anti-cancer mechanism,
DNA intercalation,
inhibition of TOPO2,
and generation of free
radicals. And some of the
others, bone marrow suppression,
mucositis, stomatitis.
A patient with a
history of rhabdosarcoma
treated with a
chemotherapy regimen that
includes vincristine
continues to suffer
from painful pins and
needles sensation,
motor weakness, and muscle
cramps in the upper and
lower extremities. What
is this adverse effect?
Peripheral neuropathy,
sensory motor peripheral
neuropathy, and the dose
-limiting toxicity of vincristine.
What is the difference
between the mechanisms of
action of the vinca
alkaloids and the taxanes?
The vinca alkaloids inhibit
polymerization of
the microtubules.
Taxanes stabilize
the microtubules and
prevent depolymerization,
disassembly. And then
they both suppress
microtubule function,
cell cycle arrest,
and mitosis and apoptosis.
A patient diagnosed with
breast cancer receives
paclitaxel intravenous infusion
once weekly every three
weeks as a component of
her adjuvant chemotherapy
regimen that includes
doxorubicin and cyclophosphamide.
What are the dose
-limiting toxicities
of each drug in the regimen?
Paclitaxel, bone marrow
suppression
Peripheral neuropathy
Doxorubicin, cardiotoxicity
Bone marrow suppression
Cyclophosphamide, bone
marrow suppression
Hemorrhagic cystitis And
I should have put here
Cardiotoxicity
I don't know why I forgot A
patient with a K-RAS Mutated
metastatic colorectal
cancer Is given the Fulferi
regimen What does IRI
Represent and what is its
dose-limiting side effect.
Arenotecan, pro-drug
converted to SN38. Topo-1
inhibitor prevents resealing
of DNA strand, leading
to strand breaks, cell
cycle arrest, and S phase.
And DNA strand breaks
cause cell cycle arrest.
This one is for the
pipidofila toxins.
What are other dose-limiting
toxicities of the drug.
Bone marrow suppression,
mucositis, stomatitis.
28-year-old male
diagnosed with testicular
cancer is treated
with the first
line regimen, which
is abbreviated BEP.
E represents a drug
that prevents resealing
of the double-stranded
breaks in DNA,
ultimately leading to
cell cycle arrest in the S
and G2 phase. What is
the name of the drug.
Etoposide, which
inhibits Topo-2,
forming that complex
drug DNA Topo-2 complex,
prevents resealing of the
double-stranded breaks,
causing irreversible
double-stranded breaks.
And as you can see,
this one belongs
down here. I just
got the order wrong.
what are the mechanisms
of action of the other two
drugs in the BEP regimen
well honestly I don't expect
you to know that it can
come up in the boards so I'm
going to mention it I'm
not going to test you on it
B stands for bleomycin which
is an anti-tumor antibiotic
and it's involved with
iron, causes pulmonary
fibrosis, which is called
bleomycin lung. We saw busulfan
lung before. This is
bleomycin lung. And then the
P stands for the platinum,
which you know all about.
Now, this treatment, BEP
regimen for the treatment
of testicular cancer,
is frequently curative.
what is an important
mechanism of
resistance common to
the anthracyclines
and the anti-tumor
natural products
efflux via upregulated
expression of
efflux pumps and I've
listed them out here
and this is a summary that
I'm not going to read to you
I gave you a little
concept map here
remember cancers are
treated according to cancer
genetics and their biology
now It's no longer,
the cancer is located in
the lung or the cancer
is located in the stomach
or wherever it's located
and therefore we pick
our treatment that way?
No. We pick our treatments
according to the genetics
of the cancer and the
biology of the cancer.
this is the conventionals
here different sites of
action it's a lot of them
that i didn't talk about
hopefully it's here just
to help you visualize the
various points various
sites of action for the
conventional chemos this is
mechanisms of resistance i made
this concept map Hopefully,
it's helpful to you.
And some tables of
all these important
points. And this
is seen in a lot of
different publications
of our chemo man.
And that concludes part one.
Oh, and of course, just
to let you know, we
have the answers here
to all the questions.
Here we go.